son épouse ainsi que ses garçons
Martin et Marc.
- Il lance, ilomompte!
- Guy Lafleur aura été le
meilleur joueur le plus
flamboyant de son époque.
- Lafleur qui s'en va droit
au but... il lance et compte!
C'est un champion!
(acclamation générale)
- Guy Lafleur  é é été
le meilleur joueur et le plus
flamboyant de son époque.
Six saisons consécutives
de plus de 50 buts, deux fois
joueur par excellence de la
Ligne nationale, trois fois
meururur marqueur du circuit et,
surtout, gagnant de cinq Coupes
Stanley, dont quatre d'affilée
avec le Canadien de Montréal.
Si sa carrière avait pris
deux ou trois saisons
à démarrer, elle a pris
fin abruptement en 1984.
Après 19 matchs, il n'avait
que cinq points, dont deux buts,
une production en deça
de ses attentes.
- Canadian's goal scores
by number 10 : Guy Lafleur!
- C'était le dernier but
de la carrière de Guy Lafleur.
- Âgé de seulement 33 ans,
il surprend le monde dckckckey
en annonçant qu'il accroche
ses patins sur-le-champ.
- Je me suis rendu au Forum puis
j'ai annoncé la décision à...
à M. Corey et à
M. Serge Savard...
que j'étai p p p prendre
- Je me suis rendu au Forum puis
j'ai annoncé la décision à...
à M. Corey et à
M. Serge Savard...
que j'étais pour prendre
ma retraite.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Canadien organise
une cérémonie où on retire
le célèbre numéro 10.
♪ ♪ ♪
Trois saisons plus tard, Lafleur
décide d'effectuer un retour
au jeu. Âgé de 36 ans,
il est invité par les Ra
de New York et le numéro 10,
qui porte le 44 lors du camp
d'entraînement, étonne à nouveau
le monde du hockey en se faisant
une place dans l'équipe
dirigée par Michel Bergeron.
Les grandes retrouvailles
avec le public montréalais
auront lieu en février 1989.
(acclamation générale)
Ovationné longuement lors
de la période d'échauffement,
Lafleur fera exploser le Forum
comme à ses belles années avec
une performance de deux buts et
une passe. Les Canadiens gagnent
le match, mais Lafleur reçoit la
2e étoile. Le public est comblé.
- De l'autre côté, c'est pour
Gusarov, le tir est bloqué
par Roy et Lafleur qui marque!
(applaudissements)
- Guy Lafleur va ensuite boucler
la boucle en allant disputer
deux autres saisons, là où
tout a commencé : à Québec.
Ses deux derniers matchs dans
la Ligue nationale seron
disputés dans l'uniforme des
Nordiques contre les Canadiens
et seront des déclarations
d'amour à son endroit.
(acclamation générale)
Cette fois, il pourra prendre
sa retraite avec le sentiment
d'avoir complété son oeuvre.
Guy Lafleur a été le meilleur
pointeur de l'hi
Canadiens devant Jean Béliveau
et le deuxième buteur
derrière Maurice Richard.mmmmmm,
Guy Lafleur aura été
le coeur et l'âme des Canadiens.
- Il faut jamais oublier
que de jouer au hockey, c'est
pas un travail. C'est un jeu.
Faut s'amuser puis faut toujours
gagner le plus possible!
(rires)
(piano mélancolique)
- À l'automne 2019, l'idole
d'une génération, Guy Lafleur,
est frappé par la maladie. f f .
Deux mois après un quadruple
poititititititit subir
l'ablation d'un lobe du poumon
touché par le cancer.
Les messages d'appui
sont venus de partout.
- Faites comme moi et rejoignez
l'équipe de Guy Lafleur!
- On te doit bien ça, Guy!
- Un an plus tard,
le cancer est revenu.
- Et faites un don pour appuyer
la recherche sur le cancer.
- Pour son dernier tour de
piste, Lafleur est ret
à ses origines. La Ligue junior
majeur du Québec a retiré
son numéro 4, en commençant à
Gatineau, tout près de Thurs
là où il est né.
(acclamation générale)
Puis, c'est à Québec que
les partisans iront le saluer.
(applaudissements)
Lors du dévoilement d'une statue
à son effigie, l'homme parlera
encore avec son coeur.
- Je me souviens q
j'étais en train de déjeuner
avec Jean Béliveau chez lui
puis... il me disait : "Tu vas
voir, ça passe... ça passe
vite." Bah! J'ai 19 ans;
ça pas q q q q q q q q que ça!
(rires)
puis... il me disait : "Tu vas
voir, ça passe... ça passe
vite." Bah! J'ai 19 ans;rararar!
(rires)
(acclamation générale)
♪ ♪